OK. Now, we're ready to move on to the eyes.
And the first thing I wanna talk about is eye contact.
And eye contact is so important in interpersonal relationships.
In fact, if someone is making more than sixty percent eye contact with you in a conversation,...
...that means they're more interested in you than what you're saying.
That's a little tip for you. Eye contact does a number of things.
One, it secures the attention of the person that you're talking to or for the person who's talking to you.
It also signals the nature of the relationship. Levels of intimacy have a whole lot to do with eye contact and comfort.
If I'm very comfortable with you, I have no problem making eye contact with you. However,...
...maybe you're my superior and you make me a little nervous,...
...so I don't make quite as much eye contact with you.
I can look away at times. It also shows interest.
I'm interested in you. I wanna look at you. I wanna understand what you're saying...
...rather than, "Hey, look at that girl. Hey, I wonder what they're doing. Hey, I'm listening."
And you're constantly looking away, "I'm not really interested."
It also can regulate the conversation.
You're talking, I'm looking, I'm listening.
I'm looking down now, because I disagree and I wanna say something.
So, eye contact is very important. Now, let's talk about eye avoidance.